Hello everybody!
Oh my god, my voice is so fucked.
Holy shit, okay.
That hello was so bad, I'm sorry.
I'm so fucked up right now.
But like, I really still wanted to play Silent Hill.
Guys, tomorrow I won't be streaming.
I will not.
I won't be streaming tomorrow, I swear.
Holy shit!
That was the most fucked up hello I've ever had in a while.
I am hydra- are you okay?
No, I am- okay, I'm gonna- I'm still sick.
I am still fucked up right now.
Okay, let me write that PSA.
PSA, I'm still sick, but that's not gonna stop me from playing Early Access!
Anyway, no stream tomorrow.
Oh my god, I'm so fucked up.
Um, I just really wanted- I really wanted to try out the Early Access.
I don't know how long I'll be playing for.
Most likely, like, I won't try to go too long.
Um, the reviews!
Everybody said the reviews overall has been really positive.
Everybody was do- also like, uh, dad is staying at the city for an extra day because I literally can't.
I was like- I was like, I'm not getting better as fast as I would like.
So I was like, alright, um, can you please take care of him for like an extra day?
And then she was like, okay.
Of course!
No problem!
He's been such a good boy!
And I'm just like, you fucking- I was like- I was like, you fucking traitor.
Fucking good boy my fucking ass.
Like, come on.
I can't believe he's been such a good boy.
Oh my god.
If I'm like, making sounds out of my mouth, but no sound- if I'm like, opening my mouth as if like, sounds are supposed to be good.
It's because I was ca- I'm coughing and I'm mooting my coughs because it's not attractive at all.
It is- it's not- it's not- it's not good.
It's- I would say it got worse.
Oh, it's a new babysitter!
I found a new babysitter to, um...
I found a new babysitter last minute because the other babysitter couldn't do it.
Because like I said, it was super last minute.
I was like, can you do it?
I need you by tomorrow.
And she's like, no.
So I was like, okay.
Like, what else am I gonna say?
Like, do it or else?
Or like- like, I had to find somebody else.
But yeah, um, it's a new babysitter.
She's also really a good babysitter.
She was expensive because it was last minute.
Um, but she gives free baths.
At least that's great.
Like, at least- at least she gives free baths.
Like, after how expensive it was.
Um, but, you know, I'll take that.
I'm tea dragon.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Zoing, Stoaky, you're going through Beale Brady!
Again!
I really, really hope the game's good.
The original one is one of my all-time favorite.
And I love Konami didn't mess this up.
Love you new emotes, by the way.
Yes!
We have new emotes if you guys don't know!
Um, it was really fast.
It was by Chica.
Um, she's like really well known in the emote community.
And, um, and honestly, Honestly, I really love how they all came out.
Like, I was like, I want all of these.
And then she did them really fast.
Literally, the sketches were done like, after I proved the sketches, the emotes were done in a day after.
So I was like, yay!
We have two more slots left, by the way.
Uh, we have two more slots left for emotes, and then it's like the maximum for emotes slots.
So after those two, we filled them all up.
And then I will finally upload the emotes on Twitch.
I'm sorry.
Twitch is very neglected right now with emotes.
I'm so very sorry.
Okay.
We'll get to that soon.
Blue, thank you for your very first Super Chat!
Thank you!
Oh god, I feel like a fucking teenager right now, with my voice cracks.
Like, I am, I'm that bro who's just going through the puberty stage at the moment.
Hi Doki, first time caller, long time listener!
Uh, thank you for your very first Super Chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Alright, let's see.
Continue.
Uh...
Seems good.
The setting seems great.
Uh...
Um, I've never played a Silent Hill game before.
I told this story already, but um, like I said, um, I have had one 10-minute experience with Silent Hill.
Um, I bought the re- like, I love, I love watch- I love the movie, the first movie.
We don't talk about the second movie, but I love Silent Hill, the first Silent Hill movie.
I really enjoyed it.
Um, it's actually one of the few faithful game adaptations at that time that came out.
Like, the director, everybody loved, like, the source material and tried their best to um, tried their best to be faithful to the source material.
The weirdest thing, the thing I hated about Silent Hill 1, uh, Silent Hill 2, is that it's Silent Hill 2, but it's based off of Silent Hill 3.
Which is understandable because Silent Hill was based off of Silent Hill...
2.
But like, it's so fucking stupid, like It's still, it's still fucking stupid that, um, um, it's just, it's such a stupid- Silent Hill 2 is such a fucking stupid movie.
Um!
Anyway!
Anyway, at least the costumes was great for Heather.
That's all I'll say.
Like, because they changed directors.
They, they changed directors, so So
I had to sneeze.
Um, they changed directors for 2 and 1.
Uh, so that's why it was a very bad movie.
I was so sad.
I didn't even watch it.
By the way, I loved Silent Hill 1 so much.
I actually went to theaters for Silent Hill 2.
But I didn't reali- I didn't Google at that time.
I wasn't smart enough to Google the movie I'm watching.
And because I didn't Google the movie, I didn't realize they changed directors.
So yeah!
I gave the fucking- I gave the studio my money to watch Silent Hill 2 in theaters.
So, yeah.
Um, Thank you, thank you!
Uh, the Silent Hill film was really good.
I'm sure I'm glad I never got a sequel to run into the ground.
Yup, just one decent film and nothing else.
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
But Silent Hill 3!
Apparently, they brought back the old director for Silent Hill 3.
So like, it might be- it might get better.
Like, they might have fixed it by Silent Hill 3 because they got back the first Silent Hill movie director.
So, it could get better.
Um, anyway!
Like I said, the only experience I had for Silent Hill are, um, is that um, I bought the remastered trilogy.
So they had like the remastered trilogy that came out on the PlayStation.
And uh, um, I didn't want to play alone.
So, I called up one of my best friends at that time.
And I was like, can you come over to my house?
And like, and then like, like watch me play this game.
Or like, you play- we play this together.
And we like, you know, exchange controllers.
So then she was like, yeah, sure, no problem.
So like, um, my mom brought up all these snacks and everything.
And it was- by the way, the sun was fucking out.
We were like, let's- like, come over to my place when the sun is out.
So it would be like, you know, 1 to 2 PM or some shit.
The sun is so fucking bright, shining in.
Um, and this was when I was in Asia.
So the sun was even more intense because it was during the summer.
So, it was during the summer.
And then we were like, alright, let's try Silent Hill 3 because we heard it's the best one out of the trilogy.
And I was like, alright.
And then so like, we like, booted it up.
We got through the dream sequence together.
It was very rough.
It took us like- it took us like, I think like, 20 minutes to get through the dream sequences because we kept passing the controller to each other.
So we were like, oh my god, fucking god, this is so scary.
So we kept passing the controller to each other because we were so fucking scared.
And the dream sequences.
And then- and then- because it was like, really fucking rough.
And then we got to the mall.
And we were like, alright, this seems great.
Like, the mall seems nice and safe.
And we got to the mall part.
And then those like, fucking giant ass creatures like, lumbering around in the mall started coming out.
And then we closed the game.
Um, and then we were like, let's play Epic Mickey 2.
My friend was like, oh hey, you have Epic Mickey 2.
We should play that.
And I was like, you're right.
There's multiplayer.
He was like, hey, there's multiplayer in that.
We should- we should play that game.
And I was like, yo, great idea.
Let's play Epic Mickey 2.
By the way, I bought Epic- I pre- I- I bought Epic Mickey, the remastered Epic Mickey.
So we're gonna play that after God of War.
So God of War will be after this.
And then after God of War, we'll play Epic Mickey.
Because I actually really- I never had a chance to play the first Epic Mickey.
Um, I bought the Epic Mickey 2, but I never finished it.
Because it was like a multiplayer game.
So like, but then like, my friend and I stopped playing it.
So then I never got to see the ending.
I never- we only got to like, the first level.
And that's it.
So I never got a chance to play Epic Mickey 1, because it was on the fucking Wii U.
It was- no, it was on the Wii.
It was on the fucking Wii.
And at that time, I didn't own a Wii.
So I never had a chance to experience Epic Mickey.
And I really want to play Epic Mickey.
So after God of War, we'll play Epic Mickey.
I never had a Wii.
My parents at that time was like, I fucking doubt those were kids.
And I was a child.
I was a child.
So like, but they were like, ew, that's for kids.
So I was like, I never had a chance.
It's like, my dad at that time, he was like, if I can't play, if I can't play, nobody can play.
So I never- At that time, I never got consoles that were meant for children.
Because like, he was like, if I can't play the video- if I can't play video games on it, nobody can play video games on it.
So I never got a chance to experience- I never got a chance to experience the GameCube, the NES, um, the, uh, like, N64, the, uh, Wii.
I got the Wii U.
And then, I finally was able to get the Wii U, um, on my birthday.
Same with the GameCube.
The only reason why I got GameCube was because it was about- the GameCube was literally dying.
Like, no new games were coming out, so it was super cheap.
Because at that time, GameCube games have already- GameCube has already been discontinued, and then that's when I got a GameCube.
So like, I had two games on the GameCube, which was- The two games I had was Animal Crossing, and- Oh wait, sorry, the three games I had was Animal Crossing, and the two- the Shadow Pokémon games.
That was it.
So like, I never got experience like, the rest of GameCube.
The rest of GameCube.
So, that was my life, when it comes to video games.
I could only play video games that were considered for real gamers.
And also, I never got experience Xbox games, so I never got a chance to play Halo or anything.
I've still never played a Halo before.
And because my dad was a Sony fucking fanboy, so he was like, ew Sony.
Until Gears of War came out.
And then when Gears of War came out, he bought an Xbox 360.
And so like, that was the only time I had a chance to experience the Xbox life.
And after that, there was never- there was never been an Xbox in my life after that.
Okay.
Um...
Alright, is it dangerous?
Maybe.
Okay, here we go.
We're gonna- not gonna be able to get- I know there's like multiple endings for this shit.
Um, I would be very surprised if we can get any good ending in this game.
Knowing me playing- knowing me, I'd be very surprised.
Cause I don't remember- I know like there's like weird ass game endings with like the dog and everything and the UFOs.
But I'd be very surprised if like, I would get any good ending here.
Knowing me when it comes to horror game.
Um, alright guys.
Uh, should I play this with a controller?
Or mouse and keyboard?
I actually- we'll just go with mouse and keyboard for now and see how it goes.
Um, I like defaulting mouse and keyboard cause I know like the main thing about- Is this James?
Okay.
I know I- guys, I bought the deluxe version just cause it's the only way to play it early.
But like, we're not- guys, we're not gonna have fucking- we're not gonna have pyramid head or mirror- we're not.
Guys, how am I gonna be immersed?
Guys!
How am I gonna be immersed?
Guys, I won't be immersed if we fucking put these on!
I won't take it seriously!
I- Okay.
Guys, I'm not gonna take it seriously if I have it on!
Alright.
The dog mask is gonna be less scary.
Okay, we'll put the dog mask on.
Um, we'll see how it goes with mouse and keyboard.
Cause like, you know, if I somehow miraculously get a gun, um, I feel- cause like, the whole point about Silent Hill is that you play a character who's like, a regular person.
So like, so that's what I'm worried about.
Cause like, you know, like, there's no actual combat in there.
So like, we might bump into- like, it's like really rare to like- MY IMMERSION!
Hahaha!
Noooo!
Okay, standard.
Uh, wait, did it reset itself?
The- wait, escape.
Did my settings res- did it not?
Okay, yeah, I was gonna say, like what?
It should've- Okay, I wanna make sure the- okay, okay, there we go.
Yeah, I was gonna say, why wouldn't- okay, 90's mode, uh, mirror interface, light, remote- difficult room that this option can be adjusted later.
Okay, if the fucking combat is too hard, we'll go easy.
If like, it's fucking me up too much.
Guys, please, I'm- don't do well.
I don't do well with- with horror, guys.
You put the mask on when it's too scary.
When it's too scary, turn the immersion off.
Hello?
Where am I?
I don't remember- cause I, like, read- I watched so many videos about the lore of Silent Hill and everything, but I don't remember.
I don't remember this game.
Like, I know the basics of this game's lore, but I don't remember the- the fuck is this?
That's my impression.
They don't know who I am until I put the mask on.
Oh my god.
It's perfect.
Y'all, why did this?
I didn't think it would start now.
Mary.
The
game looks promising already.
Oh my god, look at this asshole.
This entire time.
Look at his fucking ass.
Okay.
I see that town.
Mary.
Sorry, it paused because I had to- Oh, that's nice.
It paused so I could up the volume.
Here he is.
With his gamer headphones on.
Silent Hill, they set the title!
Title drop.
Roll credits.
You can't hear.
He has his headphones on.
Okay, let's up it a bit more.
You're a fucking whore.
I know it, James.
Even though I don't remember the lore fully of this game, I know you were a whore.
Why is the pyramid so fucking ripped, James?
Why is he so ripped?
Also, I upped it a little.
This whole town was our special place.
He's a- That's why he's wearing a dog mask, because he's a dog.
Is he really alive?
Yeah, because that's why the nurses are so hot and the fucking pyramid head was so fucking ripped.
Why does he wear the mask?
To hide his true self.
Whoa, okay!
The sensitivity is fucking insane.
Okay, give me a sec.
I forgot to- I forgot to lower something.
Okay.
The sensitivity is really fucking insane.
Holy shit.
Okay, there.
That should be good.
Oh my god!
What the fuck is the sensitivity?
Okay.
Okay, 25, 30.
Okay, that should be better, right?
What the fuck?
Okay.
Give me a sec, guys.
Jesus, why- What is wrong with the sensitivity here?
Bro, it's all- It's all the way down!
I literally have it as low as it can be.
Okay, this is- This is the best I can do.
This is actually- The fog hasn't set in so I have plenty of time before things get freaky.
By the way, I already missed Team Freaky.
Team Freaky was so good.
I think Team Freaky has to be like top three best teams I've played with.
Best pro teams I've played with in a tournament setting.
And we were like talking about how like um...
Oh wait, is it- Oh, I have to change my DPI?
Bro, if I have to change my DPI outside of the game, that is a game issue.
That is- That is a fucking game issue.
Oh, so give me a sec.
If I need a- I need a- Get more water.
Give me a sec.
I dehydrate so much because I'm sick.
Water outside.
I bought like a case of water.
I had to uber eat some more water because I don't- I need to like uber eat- Like not uber eat.
Um, when I'm better, I need to get a fucking What is it called?
A kettle?
I need to buy a kettle for hot water.
Mary always said the mask stays on, doggy.
And he matched her, freak!
That's crazy.
Yeah, they uber eats water from like a um, a store for me because like I can't go outside to buy water.
Uh, Zane, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay.
Um, oh yeah, you want to be a little bit louder.
Let's see.
I love- I love the first boss of this game, which is always settings.
Alright.
Okay, I don't rem- Like I said, I don't remember much from this game.
Um, I like watch lore videos of it, but like where do I go?
I guess I'd go to the bathroom?
No?
Can I not?
Ooh.
That's a pretty dark bathroom already.
Whoa.
Hey, that's me.
Oh my- That's scary.
That's fucking scary.
Holy shit.
That's- That's fucking- That's fucking scary right there.
Oh my god.
You can't even see those fucking face.
You're just like, who the fuck are these giant ass dogs?
Alright.
Oh, I can't go to the ladies room?
There's no one here.
I'm not like a pervert or anything.
I just want to know if there's loot.
I just- That's awful.
Okay.
Welcome.
Is that Silent Hill?
Right there?
I don't remember where- Okay.
That's- No.
That's just a lake.
Oh, there's loot in my car?
Okay.
Let's get loot in my car.
He is a pervert, but I'm not a perv- Oh shit.
Okay.
Oh shit.
That's what I actually needed.
Alright.
The map.
Okay.
We could either go to the long way or the short way.
Alright, guys.
Alright.
Let's go- Clearly, since this is a horror game, we go via the graveyard.
In honor of Spooktober, we go to the graveyard, right?
Unless there is- Unless there's something here.
Hello?
I'll set up the volume a little more sound guy.
Is there anything here?
Okay.
The road is closed.
I mean, there's another car here, so like I'm not the only person here.
See?
There's a car here and there's clearly food in the car.
So like, I'm not the only person here that's like, traveling around.
Why is there a giant dog head?
Look, I- Look, Mary in her dying words was like, please never take the mask off.
I wanna be the only wife you have.
The only woman you can have after me has to match my freak.
She has to match my exact freakiness so you can never take the mask off after I die.
So like, now he wears the mask on cause that's the only lady he can date afterwards.
It was in her will.
Yeah, she's like, you can never take- The only person you can marry or like date right after my death is the only person that can match my fucking freak.
Alright, nice.
Nice and immersion.
God, I have to look at the asshole the entire time.
I think that's the worst part.
I know there's nothing here cause I have no radio.
Um, that's another thing I remember from Silent Hill.
Like, I know there's nothing that could possibly kill me cause I don't have the radio yet that's screeching in my fucking ear to be like, MONSTER!
MONSTER!
So like, I'm not too worried right now.
Wait, how do I pick this up?
E.
Oh shit.
That's how I save?
Okay.
Mark, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Alright.
Yes, we're picking stuff up.
It's been a while, guys.
Alright.
Open the cemetery.
Hello, cemetery.
Hello!
It's an abandoned cemetery!
Legally, I can grave rob this if we learn anything.
Oh, there's that lady!
Hello, lady.
No, James.
The mask stays on.
Cosmic, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, sorry.
I know, it's the mask isn't it?
Oh, let me bring it up a little more too.
Alright.
Let me know if it's better.
Valid reaction!
Okay,
bring it up.
Sorry, lady.
You have weird game balancing issues right now.
Me?
Your kind's not welcome in Silent Hill.
What, a furry?
Sorry,
I know this is...
I know, like, not only is the mask ruining your immersion, but me trying to raise the volume of this game.
Ooh.
Me too.
I'm looking for my mama.
I mean, my mother.
My mama?
It's been so long since I've seen her.
You have fucking mommy issues, lady?
I thought... What about daddy issues?
My father... Oh no, her dad's still alive, so...
But I can't find them either.
I'm sorry, it's not your problem.
No, I... No, it's fine.
I hope you find them.
Just like how I'm gonna find my dead wife.
She's still alive, you know?
Like, I know everybody said they're was a body and everything, but like, how would there be a letter?
Hmm?
It's like those telemarketer scams.
They're like, trying to be the...
They're like, I'm your dead grandma, please send me $500,000.
And you're like, see guys?
I told you!
She's... He's alive!
She's alive!
Guys, I told you!
Why else would I get a phone call?
Did you, uh...
Did you want anything else?
No, it's just...
She's not...
She's dead, everybody!
This is why I went alone, because my therapist will think I'm crazy.
It's like, you just need to start taking off your mask.
It's been like, five years.
And I'm like, I will take off my mask when I fucking die.
Oh my god.
Oh, Jesus Christ.
Silent Hill, why are you so silent?
Okay.
Let's see.
I'm gonna check the audio for this.
Okay, yeah, the voiceover is like, fucking all the way up.
Who would've thought Silent Hill is really silent, guys?
Who would've fucking thought?
Is there any, like, loot here for me?
The hills are silent, be careful.
Can't grave rob that, you're right, James.
Fucking sucks.
I know, I know.
I could feel your I could feel your pain.
Alright.
There's no radio yet, so I know I'm okay.
I know I'll be okay.
The moment I find the radio is when I know I'm fucked.
That's okay, there's no radio yet.
There's no radio yet.
What can hurt me?
Nothing!
What the fuck?
You are not supposed to come out yet.
There's no radio yet.
You're not able to hurt me yet!
There's no siren or radio yet!
Oh, Silent Hill Ranch.
Oh, fine.
Exactly.
If anything bad happens, I have the dog in me.
Oh.
I don't like this.
I know nothing can show up now, but I don't like the ambience.
Monster incoming.
Don't say that!
There's no soundtrack yet!
This is just to build up tension!
Nothing can hurt me yet!
Yeah, I can't go here yet.
I got it.
I don't feel so good, guys.
I don't feel good right now.
I don't like this.
Oh, my god.
God, I don't like the BGM.
I don't know if you guys hear the BGM.
It's like...
I'm like, stop!
Stop!
It's just like being like, come on, you're almost there.
You're almost there!
You're almost there, Doki!
Come on!
We can't keep playing that one instrument!
Okay, here we go.
Oh, I don't like it.
I know it's like...
supposed to raise up tension and everything, but god, it fucking sucks.
Do we go through that door?
Or...
Does it need a key?
Oh, it does.
Okay, I...
I don't know...
I don't know if you said up more and already did up more, or like, you need me to put it up more right now.
Oh, my god.
Dude, fuck me.
Why am I playing this game?
God damn it.
I did promise I would play this game eventually.
Went down to get the window fixed.
Spare key in the drawer.
Okay.
Oh, my god.
I feel really scared right now.
I don't like it.
Okay.
Anyone in here?
Hello?
Did I break into your fucking house?
Okay, yeah, I have to.
No name.
Don't say that.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, my god.
Sir.
Like, I know I'm breaking into your house, but sir, why is your...
Sir, you need to clean up, bro.
Oh, god.
The soundtrack is too good.
I hate the soundtrack so much.
It's too good, so I hate it.
Okay, auto service and tires.
Okay.
Is there anything else that he owns that I can take from him?
God, when they do too good of a good job.
Okay.
Hello.
There was nothing else there.
Guess you did not see anything.
Guys, there's no radio siren yet, guys.
No, you don't.
You don't hear anything.
I know.
Don't fuck with me.
I stole one thing.
Wait, there's a gun?
There's a gun?
Okay.
Swear to god.
Are you sure?
Okay, not here.
Okay.
Alright.
The gun, did you see it?
That's a lie.
Don't fuck up.
I have never played this game before, so I don't believe anything.
It's right there, Toki.
I've never played this game before, so you know I don't believe anything.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
Alright.
You guys know I'll believe it.
Oh god.
I'm just a regular guy.
I don't think I've even operated a gun before.
Oh, I don't like this.
There's gonna be dogs, too.
There's gonna be doggos, and then there's gonna be nurse, hot nurses.
And then there's gonna be hot pyramid heads.
And then like...
Do they keep the scene with the pyramid head and the nurse?
Oh my god.
Because that shows how fucking fucked up James is.
Okay.
Blackfire, thank you for the file.
Thank you.
Burrito, thank you for the super chat.
My greatest fear is humans with dog masses.
I saw one walk by, which means I'm the main character in this Silent Hill game.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh.
Oh no.
There's the fog.
James, why can't you pick another day to come to Silent Hill?
Like, just look at the weather forecast, James.
Like, I don't understand.
Oh my god.
I don't understand.
You could literally pick any other day.
You could be like, what is the weather forecast in Silent Hill?
Like, why did you have to fucking...
No, he can't bring a homie.
They don't match his freak right now.
He doesn't like...
He's so... I don't think his homies are even associating with him.
He's never taking his mask off since she died.
Since Mary died.
Nothing can stop it.
Like, you could have waited one more day.
She's like...
Technically, you know she's like dead dead.
So like, what's one more day?
It's not like she'll suddenly die right after sending that letter.
Okay.
But Larius, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wait.
Like, why is there a dead end right here?
Like, was there supposed to be anything here?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The nurses are extra creepy because it means James was thinking those thoughts about every damn woman in his life.
I told you.
But he can't do anything about it because he promised Mary.
That's why he's never taking it off.
Okay.
Where am I?
Do we go here?
Or here?
I hate that they give me choices.
I don't want free will.
Can I imagine you yell me a chat into the time mask?
It's that thing.
Oh, okay.
Don't do anything here.
I can't open doors.
Why is the hill so silent?
No trespassers.
Visitors must register at the main office.
What?
How fucking secluded is Silent Hill?
What do you mean no visitor?
A small town would love tourists.
Wouldn't you think a small town would actually want more tourism?
Or like extra income?
That's when you know.
That's when you know it's fucking weird.
Oh my god.
Why is the hill so silent?
Guys, stop!
It's here!
Oh my god, did you see?
Did you see?
Okay, I have the other map.
Oh shit.
Okay.
That's a lot of places.
Okay, here we go.
Oh my god.
This is the entire area.
Alright.
This is where I have to go now.
Oh my god.
Oh fuck.
Okay, now.
This is the worst part.
Do enemies respawn?
Before I go straight into the hill.
Do...
Do the enemies respawn?
I need to know .
I need...
Okay, they can't Alright, now I know.
I cannot waste my bullets.
Okay.
Okay, now I know.
Guys, I need a...
This is crucial information.
Guys, this is actual crucial information.
This Silent Hill is all about making sure you have enough materials.
I need a no.
Do they respawn?
Guys, please.
Please, this is so important.
This is...
Oh my god.
This is so important.
I need a no if they respawn.
Okay.
It's early access.
It doesn't mean this game didn't come out 20 plus years ago, chat.
This...
It's a remake, not a fucking...
Not a new IP.
Miss Cassandra.
A customer came in today ordering mixed bouquet, red and white.
I tried to explain his bad luck.
He just won.
He seemed a bit off.
Looked at me like I wasn't even there.
Then he just left.
Said he'd be back to pick him up later.
I just want to let you know since...
Oh my god, my fucking cursor is a fucking knife.
Since I must be gone by then.
Okay.
Alright, cool.
Okay, they respawn.
Okay, that is good to know.
So now, now I know I can... I could just run.
Cause like, if they didn't respawn, I'd just kill everything.
And then fucking pray to god I'll...
Oh, that's blood.
What is... I don't know.
James, fucking touch it.
And then you'll realize it's blood.
I fucking know it.
I look down.
I'm not even in this world with you.
And I know it's blood.
Okay.
James, Jesus fucking Christ.
Of course it's fucking blood.
Like...
Like I'm not even in this world with you right now.
Like I'm not even in this game world.
It's just red dirt.
Oh god, okay.
Alright, here we go.
Here we fucking go.
Like, do I get any...
Give me a fucking weapon!
Oh my god, I hate this.
Oh, there's more blood.
Here it is.
More of that.
Yeah!
That stuff!
Touch it, James!
Then you'll know exactly what it is!
Sorry, he doesn't want to get his mask dirty, which is understandable.
Where the fuck do I go?
They gave me free will and I hate that!
Follow the...
Why the fuck would I follow the blood?
Blood stops!
I guess it goes this way?
Who in their right mind would follow the fucking blood?
You would like run away from the blood.
Oh...
Oh, there's another trail of blood!
There it is!
Okay...
I mean, he literally ran off here without telling anybody that he's in Silent Hill because his dead wife sent him a letter.
And, um...
And even though you know, he could have told his therapist too.
Like, I'm pretty sure he's in therapy.
There's no way he's not.
Oh, there he is.
Oh, that's... I remember this scene.
That's an infamous scene.
Right there.
Yeah!
Fucking James, what is that?
Holy shit, what kind of freak is that?
Hey, wait!
Oh yeah, bro, that's someone you clearly wanna follow.
Hey, wait up!
Hey, contortion man!
You're clearly in trouble!
You could...
Like, even if I don't know anything about the Silent Hill monsters, I would say he was a mental asylum patient that escaped!
You know?
It looked like he was in a straitjacket!
That's a good idea, you fucking idiot!
Okay, let's keep going.
Yeah, let's follow the crazy person that's fucking contorting.
Bro didn't want anyone to out-freak his freak.
London Simulator 2024.
Yavi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god.
Here we go.
Up we go.
Here we go!
Error closed off due to an accident.
Trespassers might lead to injury or death.
Alright.
Guess we don't go that way.
Wait, what way do we go?
I saw him fucking contorting, but...
What?
Did I just go the other way?
Did he just disappear and then I just have to live with it?
Oh no, it's the alleyway.
Okay, nevermind.
Nevermind, let's go to the dark, dingy alleyway.
You go, James.
You fucking go.
Go fucking enable his trauma.
Let's go.
Let's not seek help at all.
Alright.
This is like never, don't do what James does the game.
If your wife is dead, seek help.
Don't be like him.
It kinda sucks that James is my name and every time Doki insults James, it feels like she's insulting me.
It should have been me!
Thank you for the super chat, James.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, this is what happens when you avoid therapy, guys.
God, you can't even jump.
Like, what good are you?
Let's go through.
Oh shit!
What the fuck?
Bro, he just slinked away.
Yeah, let's follow it!
Let's go!
What would my therapist do?
Not that!
What would my therapist tell me to do?
Don't do that?
Ha!
If I listened to my therapist, I wouldn't even be here.
Nothing you've done so far was in the Silent Hill 2 game.
And the Dufflers say they changed the combat system.
You're literally in... No.
No, Cory.
No.
You're literally in uncharted area.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki is a friend that yells at the people in the horror film the entire time.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, ninja.
Alright.
Let's see.
I'm the person that won't die in a horror game.
Because the moment I see something fucky, I'm like, I'm out.
I'm just like...
I'm fucking leaving.
Okay, I don't know if this is...
I think this is 90.
And then we'll boost it up just a little bit more.
Alright, here we go.
Alright.
Uh...
Okay, here we go.
CZ, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
First time super chatting for anyone on YouTube, but I had to let you know, I've been following since you modded Fillion and modded Opi, and I love your laugh so much.
Thank you!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
I'm glad you've been enjoying my content.
Look around to find an object marked by a white cloth.
Those are objects or traversals you can interact with.
And why not yellow paint?
I'm stupid.
Can't believe it.
This is why this game didn't get perfect 10 out of 10.
There was no yellow paint.
Hahahaha.
White cloth?
Fucking amateur move bloom.
Amateur blooper.
Hahaha.
Oh shit.
Oh, guess I can't go back.
Ugh, I hate this.
I actually hate this so much.
There's no way they're gonna make me fight this person without a fucking weapon.
There's no fucking way.
At best, it's just gonna scare me.
Ugh.
Okay.
What does this say?
Oh, it says zone.
Okay.
This damn mess takes up like 30% of the stream.
Good luck if anything comes at you.
You're at 11 o'clock.
Thank you.
Thank you for this.
Yeah, it would be fucking awkward if the enemy was right in front of that blind spot.
That one blind spot right there.
Hahaha.
That would be so awkward.
Literally the only blind spot that like I need to be able to see right there.
Alright.
The moment it gives me a weapon, I know it's fucking over.
Okay, nutrition.
Alright, I got health drinks.
Press V to drink.
Okay, I know like I is my inventory.
Oh, I have memo.
Oh, it's just the... what's my personal?
Oh, that's Mary's letter.
That's her!
From when she was still healthy.
As a fellow I can confirm we're a bit freaky with poor decision making.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, I don't like that.
Okay.
Oh my God, please.
Oh, this is not going so well.
I actually heard it.
Oh, the static.
Here it comes.
I hear the static.
No more...
What if I just never pick that up?
Okay.
Do I have to?
Can I just go through the game without picking it up?
Oh, here we go!
James is just staring at us like, do I take it?
It's time.
Oh, no.
There it is!
And so it begins.
Love the content, Toki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Chemical.
Oh my God.
Can I just not?
There we go!
The game starts now!
Oh,
there he is too!
Oh, he's about to vibrate!
Hello.
Oh, shit.
There he is.
Contortion man.
Oh, shit.
You're freaky too?
Damn.
Is this like a bondage thing?
Yo, me and my dead wife used to have a thing too.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, grab that fucking nail in the plane.
Jesus.
I'm not gonna ask any questions.
Alright.
Get out.
Oh, fuck!
I'm sorry!
How the fuck was I supposed to know he was gonna do that?
Get down!
Fucking die!
That's right!
Oh my God.
This is what was missing in my life too, I guess.
I gotta make sure.
Bro.
Gotta make sure he's dead dead.
Okay, he's definitely dead.
Okay.
Is that what I saw?
I don't fu- James, yes it is!
How the fuck?
Yes!
What do you mean your question- I think you got it.
Are you guys sure?
Can't be sure.
I need it.
Come on!
I don't know!
I don't know the anatomy of this fucker!
Like...
Extreme.
One more for the road.
The double tap.
The 20 tap.
I just- I don't know!
How was I supposed to know he was dead dead?
How do you go from woods to cereal?
Cause it was one guy!
Like...
It was one guy!
He literally had nothing on him.
All he had was his legs.
All he had in him was literally his legs.
Okay, gotta make sure.
It's when we get to the dogs when it gets scary.
Cause dogs can't run.
And when there's more than one of them maybe it's still alive!
Maybe ten more love taps will do the trick.
It's like when there's four of them where I have to freak out cause it's like it gets a little more difficult to fucking do anything.
Alright.
That radio was in different location?
Oh no.
Are you fucking serious?
Oh yes!
The dirty fucking meat- fucking my mask!
My fucking mask!
Guys, you can't even see the item!
A giant ass head is blocking the item!
Okay, we can sort of tell there's a dirty fucking syringe.
Alright, nice.
Okay.
Alright.
It's fine.
Also, like, don't fucking random- James!
Please!
Please, you're going through a downward spiral.
James, please don't use don't use a random needle you found in the- James, please.
Please don't use this needle you found in the fucking floor.
It's not- James.
Holy shit.
Come- What?
Mary?
I knew I wasn't crazy.
I knew that what body wasn't yours.
I knew it.
I knew you got a body double and faked your death.
They call me crazy.
You sound just like a therapist.
James!
I'm crazy.
Why do I hear her voice right now?
I don't need meds!
I don't need that I'm not hearing voices!
Okay.
Look at me now, therapist.
How's that for well adjusted?
Zane, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What voices?
They were all real.
I fucking knew it.
It validated my- It validated me.
I knew it was real.
Okay.
It's the meds.
I knew it.
I stopped taking the meds so I could hear her again.
Where are you, Mary?
Alright.
I guess we go down this Martin Street.
There's nowhere else to go.
When will we get to the sexy nurses?
That's the better question.
Did you see him, Toki?
We're not real.
No, you're real because I didn't take my meds!
You're so real!
Oh, that's a dead body.
Yeah, that's a fucking dead body.
Newly's Bar.
Okay, do I go there?
I guess I go there, right?
Oh, there we go.
Okay, I have to go to Newly's Bar.
Uh...
Hermandus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What the fuck?
What?
The fuck was that?
My radio didn't go crazy yet.
If you're reading this, leave.
This place is not what it seems.
Sometimes you just have to look.
Run away.
Okay, I'm gonna use the bathroom.
Only did I use the bathroom.
I also turned on the lights outside.
I turned on the lights in my hallway.
Alright!
Okay.
Okay, that's...
Alright, that's reassuring.
That's... That's reassuring.
She did run away.
Alright.
Off we go to see the wonderful Wizard of Oz.
Whoa!
There he goes!
Okay, that's a little...
I can't take that seriously.
The way he fucking just crawls like that.
Like...
What the fuck?
There's a giant... That's a fucking rat!
It's... What the fuck was... Okay.
Did they always crawl like that?
There's... There's no way!
There's no way they always crawled like that.
What the fuck was that?
Are there items behind me?
Oh my god.
There's no way that's how they move.
There's no fucking...
What?
What kind of dog was that?
Cas, thank you for the super chat.
I'm just making sure there's no items here.
There's no way!
There's no way they used to crawl like that in the first game.
Okay.
Oh my god.
What a weird looking dog.
Oh.
Ooh.
Whoa.
Can I read that note before, like, anything happens to me?
God, it's when he looks back at you.
When he looks back at you.
This strange dog.
Anything here?
What a strange dog.
It doesn't matter if he wears the dog head.
It's just freaky in general when he looks back at you like that.
Oh, there he is.
He's crawling again.
Cas, I'm not gonna run.
It just makes it scarier when I'm running.
I feel more comfortable, like, walking at a leisurely pace.
Okay.
Cas, I'll go this way.
I don't know.
It just feels more comfortable just walking over.
Cas, it's like there's nothing chasing me right now.
So, like, I don't know.
There's no need to run if there's nothing chasing me.
So, like, we get to absorb our... Oh, there he is.
Hello.
Hey.
Whoa!
Ah, shit!
Okay.
That's not a good dodge.
I don't know when he fucking does the thing!
Like, how am I supposed to know?
Get down!
Don't worry.
My stick is not gonna break.
Right?
Oh, god.
I hope he doesn't break.
Okay.
We're five.
Alright.
Do I have self-heal?
I don't think I have self-heal.
Equipment.
Oh, yes.
A wooden plank.
Okay.
Stop resisting!
Alright.
I don't know when he, like, charges up the kick.
Use the needle?
I don't wanna use the needle.
Guys, like, what if I get, like, a fucking like, what if I get isn't, like, like, what are those diseases you get from sharing needles?
Like, is my radio even on?
It never even fucking went Okay.
I need to know my inventory.
The fuck is my radio?
No, it is on.
Okay.
Yeah, I could get, like, James is gonna get AIDS!
You don't want James to get AIDS?
Okay, put down to 90?
Okay.
Alright.
What was it?
Ambient or effects?
I assume it's effects, right?
Okay.
Effects.
There we go.
HIV?
STD?
I could get everything!
We don't know where this needle's been?
Okay, I'll use the needle.
Oh, I drank the health potion.
Okay.
That's a lot better.
Alright, we'll use the needle as a last resort.
Hello, sir.
I'm coming for you!
Okay.
Oh, now he vomits?
Okay, there we go.
I got the strap down.
That's right.
Get down!
There we go.
They're not real, so this isn't murder.
Guys.
They're not real, so it's not murder.
Okay, I just need to hit once and then run.
And then dodge.
That's the strat.
I'm literally beating up my imagination, guys.
Like, at best, I'm just a sociopath.
Like...
That's like, at best...
At best, I'm a sociopath.
And at worst, I'm a psychopath.
I'm literally just beating up my imagination.
Ah, jeez.
Why is...
Get down.
Oh, shit!
You double-tap?!
It's cause he crawled on the ground!
Bro, don't make me use my needle!
Holy shit.
God, I wish they dropped loot.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, there's a police car.
Clearly.
That should be a good sign.
Where the fuck is the bar?
They look like monsters to you!
They're not real!
They're not real people!
I'm not murdering anybody, I swear!
Okay, it's here.
They're trying to make me use my fucking needles!
Hello?
Oh, this seems safe.
I don't know what got into him, but he just started smashing the thing.
I had to throw him out.
He ran up, cried.
He fixed everything.
I gathered up what I could.
I still haven't found one of the buttons.
Half the record is still lodged inside, but the other part is missing.
Figured he must have come to think of it.
He did run towards Groovy.
Anyway, maybe go check up on him, if he's alright.
He lives over at Salt by the pharmacy.
Apartment 9.
Okay, I feel like I have to go back.
Apartment 9?
Or whatever the fuck?
Okay, there's apparently something at the police trunk.
There was a police car?
Guys, I was doing so much murder, I couldn't tell.
Not murder, sorry, just, you know, beating up my imagination.
I can't even open this.
Liars?
There's nothing here.
Ugh.
Ugh, I don't like that.
Oh, can I use my plank?
This?
Oh, shit.
And now what?
There's nothing here though.
The fuck do I break the police car for?
Nothing here.
Now I'm a criminal.
No!
My chat told me to!
Like...
I just got...
Fuck the police.
No!
Now I am a criminal!
This is my chat's fault!
They told me to do it!
No!
I got it.
I got baited!
There was no reason for me to beat up the cop car!
That is vandalism, Toji.
You guys told me to vandalize!
I thought get lewd!
I can't believe I can't believe you guys baited me into fucking vandalism.
I was just fucking beating up like my imaginary enemy, my imaginary friends.
Chad told you to.
I didn't take my meds, officer!
Thank you for the super challenge, I'll take a thank you.
What is this?
Oh, is this a puzzle?
Fuck.
Okay, fuck.
I wish I could see what that is.
It's a yellow disk.
No,
it's a jukebox.
Okay.
What the fuck?
What the fuck am I supposed to do?
Oh, okay.
Not that?
Oh, I need to find a vinyl.
It's for later?
Well, I sort of solved it.
Okay.
I just need to find the item.
No, I totally- I barely solved it!
Okay, I can't be here yet.
I need a key.
Okay.
No, you didn't?
Then what the fuck did I do?
What?
Is that not it?
Yeah, I can't do anything right now.
I don't have a thing to fix that.
I'm not fucking engine- I don't even know what my actual job is.
Like, what's my job?
What do I- There was a hole here, it's gone now.
What?
What do I do?
Do I have to go to the apartment?
Oh, I have to go to the music store!
To get the thing!
Do I go to the apartment first or the music store?
Where do I go first?
Oh yeah, is that the reference to the game where I was trapped in the room?
Up to you.
Play it for you.
I don't know.
Which one do I do?
The music store or the apartment?
Guys, I don't like free will.
I don't- This is not in the original!
Okay, apartment is progress?
Okay, I'll go to the music store then.
Alright.
I don't have a lot of meds, I just realized.
Which is great, because I don't- Which is great, guys, by the way.
It's like...
You know...
I don't want to prove the doctors right.
Alright, off to the music store I'll go.
Look, there's the dead guy.
Alright.
I gotta make sure!
What if it comes back to life?
Chat!
Alright, I hope the maps are actual pauses, because I'm like fucking progressively lost.
Alright.
Double tap.
I don't know when they come back, like Resident Evil.
We'll have to go through to get to the furry convention!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Alright.
Alright, music store.
Oh, there he is.
Alright, get over here.
If I hit first...
Oh, fucker!
And now you kick me!
You're such a whore!
Why am I such a pervert?
Oh my god!
The third party!
Oh my god, the third party out of nowhere!
Oh my god, I'm only...
I'm a whore.
They're a whore because I'm a whore.
Now I'm angry!
Oh, there's one there.
Nice.
Alright.
Oh my god, geez.
Why are you such a pervert?
I got handgun ammo.
I don't even have a gun yet.
Why am I such a pervert?
It's true though!
That's the reason why they're all so freaky!
It's like...
Oh no!
Why did I have to think of them like this?
I already broke one police car.
What's one more?
PSA in the Silent Hill games, you don't need to kill every enemy in the streets if you want to save.
Who knows?
It's the same here.
Too late.
I'm gonna do something wild.
Oh, I don't have... Oh, the syringe is not health?
What do you mean the syringe isn't health?
Okay, alright.
There we go.
Alright guys, I have no more health.
Oh no, how could I possibly avoid that?
How could I possibly avoid using my health?
Oh man.
If only I know how.
If only there was a way to stop me from that.
Hello?
Oh no.
Okay.
Oh, there's two.
Like, can I just...
Okay, if I like...
What?
Okay.
The fucking projectile bomb that gets me there?
That's fucking dumb.
Fuck off.
Okay, that's not fair.
Can I like... That's not fair.
Like, what the fuck is this range?
Oh my god.
Like, what is this garbage brain set?
You fucker!
You double tapped!
Now it's a vomit too?
Holy shit.
Okay.
James, you're such a fucking freak.
Bro, I literally just killed.
Oh my god.
This is all your fault, James.
I couldn't even read.
Okay, where's my memo sheet?
Oh my god.
I just literally healed too.
Okay, uh, investigate.
There we go.
The janitor came the other day, drunken in tears.
Had half a record with him.
Kept yelling we gotta fix it somehow.
I was willing to do it just to shut him up.
So, I got up to get the glue from the cabinet, but then he realized he only had one half, so he ran out.
Can't do much about the record.
Maybe ask your Aunt Neely's next time you're there.
Might be one of theirs.
Oh my god.
I can't bel- It is his fault!
This is like in his mind!
It's literally his fault!
Alright, here we go.
Like, James!
God, if you were gonna imagine these freaks.
Bro, keep it out of the fucking bedroom.
Like, sorry, keep it in the bed- Sorry, no, keep it in the bedroom.
Holy shit.
Face the music.
Oh my god, I'm dying.
I'm actually di- Ow!
They're the easiest enemies!
How am I dying, you fucker!
I can't tell!
Your patterns are are so inconsistent!
Like, you vomit, and then you fucking headbutt, and then you kick!
There's no windup!
There's no fucking windup!
Like- There's- There's no- There's no windup!
I was playing Wukong for so long!
Like- It's not fair.
It's not fair!
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, let's unlock this door.
I know, like, I didn't have to break, like, three windows, but I'm literally dying right now.
Like, I feel like I'm exempt from that.
I'm literally fucking dying.
Okay.
Alright.
Is there any heals?
Like, where are the fucking heals?!
Where are the heals?!
Holy shit!
Where's the mechas in this game?!
Oh my god.
Oh, there it is.
Thank god.
Okay.
Drink.
Drink, my boy.
Okay, I found one heal.
Thank god.
Who the fuck puts a health thing in the cabinet?
Now I'm gonna smash everything.
They're so aggressive!
They don't need, like- The doors don't wind up!
Literally, they just fucking- They just beat the shit out of me!
They just go in and beat the shit out of me!
Like, what the fuck?
Oh my god.
They just go right in and just start throwing up, headbutting, kicking and screaming.
Okay, here we go.
Swear to fucking god.
The door that wakes in darkness opening into nightmares.
Oh, I guess that's where German Head is.
Is there extra loot?
Please.
I'm so desperate.
Oh my god.
Kingdom Hearts?
The door that was- Okay.
What?
I don't like that.
Okay, I clearly can't go in yet.
Oh my god.
Who cares?
Who cares about this man's fucking car?
What about me?
Guys, do you care about me?
I don't remember this part, Sora.
Gosh, Sora.
It seems we're in Silent Hill.
What the fuck?
Oh shit, he's fucking crawling.
Oh shit, oh.
Whoa, what the fuck?
That hits me!
He's laying on the ground!
Oh my god!
You fu- How?
How the fuck you?
Fuck you!
I hate this game.
He's just nipping my ankles and I still get hit.
I can still get fucking hit.
This is so bullshit!
I fucking nipped my ankles and it fucked me up!
Oh my god, I'm not having a good day at Silent Hill.
Your patterns are inconsistent.
The man was here again.
I told him he's been warned not to come here.
He acted like he didn't know what I was talking about.
Anyway, he got up and left.
He didn't make any sort of fuss, but there's something about him that gives me the creeps.
When I look at his face, it looks like I'm staring- Oh my god, it's me!
I'm staring at a mask.
And there's something underneath waiting to get out.
I don't want to be there when that happens.
That's me.
There's another man with a mask?
How dare he?
Can I explore this diner more?
God, I don't fucking know anymore.
It's so lit.
This is the reason why I hate survival.
Oh my god, are you fucking serious?
Get over here.
Get your ass- Yeah, yeah, I'm talking about you!
Yeah, I'm talking about you!
Get your ass over here!
Yeah, stop looking- I'm talking to you!
Yes, you!
Oh, you're gonna walk away, you fucker!
Get you over here, you fuck!
Oh, he's just gonna walk- Oh, this little asshole.
Get over here.
Get your ass over here, I'm talking to you!
Yes!
Come on!
They scared- Come here!
Oh, you guys throw up, aren't ya?
That's fucking right.
God, use your stupid projectile vomit!
Your stupid ass projectile vomit right now.
Oh, you think I don't know?
Are you so- Oh my god, I was gonna say- I was gonna say, if he fucking like- Oh god.
God.
Dodge!
That's right!
I fucking downloaded- Oh, he just missed it, guys.
That's fucking right.
Get down, you freak.
Hopefully.
Shit.
Okay.
Alright.
Good.
That's good that he came over.
I needed that.
I hate that guy so much.
I hate these monsters.
They're like the easiest monsters, too!
That's the worst part!
They're like the easiest.
They're like the easiest ones in the game, so this is the worst part for me.
Alright, I'm abusing the third person.
I'm abusing it.
I just gotta be sure there's nothing over on this side.
Wait, what?
Excuse me?
Are you- What?!
You don't die.
You're such a fucking whore!
You're actually a whore!
Forever!
Oh my god.
There's no way.
I even triple tapped.
I even triple tapped!
I- I can't believe it.
I- I didn't know that.
I fucking...
How many taps does it take?!
How many?!
Is that too serious?
Are you fucking...
I can't...
I can't... I can't believe it.
I can't believe they're still alive!
I can't believe it!
Okay.
I can't believe it.
I even triple tapped him too!
I can't!
Please!
There's no way!
Please, I don't have someone in this bed!
Does he- Does he revive?!
There's no way.
Are you- Are you gonna come back?
I- I think he is dead.
I need to know!
I can't!
I don't have a lot of health!
Is he dead?
Are you sure it's the- You're right.
You're right.
I'm sure.
Is he dead for real?
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Get up!
Don't you fucking pretend!
I need to know!
I need to know if you just respawn!
I need- You're like my science experiment if you'll just get up!
Are you just gonna get up?
No, right?
He's dead, right?
I just- I need to be sure!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Alright.
Here I go!
Just in case.
I just gotta be sure.
Okay.
I swear to god if I go into this room and get back up, I swear to fucking god.
Just a- OH!
IT'S THE FUCKING RAT!
God!
You're such a fucker!
I knew it!
I fucking knew it!
I knew you were pretending!
I knew it!
I fucking knew it!
You can't fool me!
You can't fucking fool me!
You fucking...
I knew it!
I knew you were waiting!
You can't fool me twice!
You can't trick me!
Okay...
Okay, what is up there?
Before I leave...
He went inside!
I knew it!
I fucking knew it!
Alright...
Thank you for the super chat!
Bro was about to prank her...
What is actually up there?
I know what's up there, but he's actually trying to fucking cat me!
Okay...
IT'S JUST A... THERE'S NOTHING HERE!
IT'S JUST AN UNKILLABLE MAD MONSTER!
LIKE THAT'S...
Oh my god, he's literally just an unkillable monster for no reason!
Like...
That's...
Holy shit...
There was no reason for him to be there!
There's...
There's nothing there!
He's a little silly...
Are you...
Oh my god, they all respawn!
Oh my god, well...
They don't even drop loot!
That's the worst part!
They drop nothing!
He's a silly guy!
I can't believe I wasted so much meds on these unkillable freaks!
Okay...
Oh my god...
I'm gonna use the new empty save...
But I knew it!
I knew it!
How many times do I have to teach you this old lesson?
See?
Oh my god, I thought them...
No, it's the worst part!
There's no infinite item glitch!
Okay, I have to go to the apartment now.
He's just a silly little guy.
God, he's the silliest.
Okay...
These unkillable freaks are like the bane of my existence.
I literally wasted three fucking meds for these guys.
Like, I thought I could kill them!
Does this give me a pause?
I don't know.
I'm just gonna leave.
The worst part is that they're gonna jumpscare me because I'm not looking back.
Alright.
I don't have the other half of it.
I don't have the other half of the record so I can't repair it.
How do I get to this guy's apartment?
Please don't follow me.
I'm trying to figure out how to get to this apartment.
Oh, there.
Hello?
This sucks.
This fucking sucks!
Now I know they come back to life!
That's the worst part!
I hate it here.
I fucking hate it here.
Heels!
Oh god, the static.
I'm mad.
Fuck this bug.
At least he doesn't come back to life.
At least he doesn't.
Fuck this.
Fuck this bug.
Fuck this one bug just because he doesn't come back to life.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh, there's the key.
Number five.
At least I can see the key.
Do you have health?
Oh, nobody has health!
Number five left his key.
Says there's a leak from upstairs.
Gotta check it out.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's go.
Oh my god.
I hate these freaks.
God, James.
Why can't you think happier thoughts?
Like, I know your wife died from a fucking, like, disease and you gotta watch her die, but like, just be happier.
You know, those people just stop being depressed.
Just be happy.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Let's see.
Wait, I missed something?
What did I miss?
I got everything.
Just don't be sad.
The key is the world's shittiest.
I've never said I was licensed.
Didn't miss anything.
Oh, I could just unlock this door.
Yeah.
That's how it works.
James, everything could have been avoided if you just stopped being depressed.
That's...
Stop.
Okay.
And also, if you had friends.
You clearly don't have friends.
Like, all your friends had to be your wife's friends and now they don't hang out with you because, you know.
What the fuck is...
That looks like a person right there.
That freaked me out.
Yeah.
Let's see.
Wait.
Heals have diminishing returns each time so good luck with dodging.
Wait, what does that mean?
Wait.
What?
I can't believe I used all my heals on these fuckers.
I'm so sad.
Like, I didn't know.
I didn't know they...
I didn't know they'd come back to life.
I can't tell if you're fucking with me sometimes, chat.
I thought you guys were fucking with me.
I wouldn't have wasted my heals if I knew that.
I didn't know they're so bullshit.
Okay.
Um...
Me when I lie.
Alright.
Okay.
450.
Can I have those?
I didn't know.
I thought they stayed dead forever.
And then I have to watch one of them just come back to life being like heh heh.
Booyah.
Okay.
Oh, come on.
I didn't remember.
I didn't remember they came back alive.
All I remember was like...
like they were... they burned the cop lady.
Where is he?
I don't like this.
Clearly here.
Like, he's clearly here!
Okay, that's where I have to go.
What?
Like, he's here!
Oh.
Oh no, guys, I'm scared.
Guys, I'm scared.
Okay, I gotta be... oh, I'm scared.
I'm actually scared, guys.
Wait.
Why is there a cubby here?
Knock knock!
Okay.
Can I go upstairs?
Oh my god.
I hate this.
Oh, I hate this.
Okay, knock knock!
Apartment key.
I know you're here.
I know you're a freak and you're here right now waiting for me to go over here and it'll be like, peek-a-boo!
Don't think I don't know video games.
Don't think I don't know fucking video games.
You're gonna come up and be like, peek-a-boo!
Okay.
Here I'll go.
Peek-a-boo time.
Sorry, my head, my fucking John-ass dog head is in the way.
Is it?
The fuck was my- oh no, that's not it.
That's not it.
The peek-a-boo is coming.
I can feel the peek-a-boo.
I can feel the peek-a-boo hours.
Okay.
I'm ready to be peek-a-booed.
Run!
Where is it?
Peek-a-boo?
Peek-a-boo hours?
Oh my god, this is way too quiet.
He's waiting.
He's definitely waiting for me.
The fuck?
Okay.
Up I go.
Jesus Christ.
This fucking bitch.
Alright.
Up the window I go.
I hate this.
I already hate this game so much.
And then she came and washed it all away.
It all started to make sense now.
Not that it's a bad game, just that I'm scared.
It's doing what it's good at doing.
It's doing what it's doing.
It's just this place I can't fight it.
Gotta get my head straight.
Quick stop at Texan and then we're going.
Yes I'm fucking scared.
Yes I am.
I fucking hate horror games.
But like I promised you guys I would play Silent Hill 2.
And here it is.
They remade Silent Hill 2.
But like Oh my god.
Why is there three fucking doorways?
Guys.
Oh.
Oh there's a hole.
Fucking let me look through this.
Guys.
There's a hole.
Surely.
Oh let me put my hands through there.
Let me put my hands.
Wow.
Holy shit.
Guys if I If I put my hands through the hole.
No.
Okay.
Would I have to file a harassment claim with HR if I put my hands through the hole?
Don't do it.
That's the James I remember.
Oh my god.
Papa Smirt thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Don't you refuse to run.
Get scratched while scrolling.
Go on a rampage and kill them all while screaming.
You have found the hole James.
I don't know now.
I don't know yet.
There's actually Guys I feel like this is a bad hole.
Yes.
I feel like I don't.
It's a bad hole.
Yes.
I I Open the door first.
What if it's a bad hole?
Alright for content I'll Alright.
James being a coward is not you.
Was this a bad hole?
Hey no it's fine.
Hey look at that.
It's covered in blood.
Look at that.
We won't fuck off.
We won't try and figure out where that blood came from.
Alright.
Look at that.
Okay.
We won't try and figure out where that came from guys.
It's fine right?
Alright.
Don't have to file a claim.
And now we see what's in the hole.
What's in the door?
What did my hand touch?
I guess we'll never know.
I guess we'll never know what my hand touched.
And we'll never know.
Alright.
Oh hey.
Is there anything here?
I feel like I can go down from here.
But then there's a door here so I don't know.
Oh.
Okay, I guess we're not going that way.
Why give me a door if I can't go down?
Like, what?
What's the point of giving me that door?
Where am I?
This got pranked.
Quite literally the troll.
Okay, where do I go?
I'm here now.
We just gotta go to the bar.
Alright, I think it's this way.
I hope this pauses the game when I'm in the map.
I swear to god, if I get slapped by these fuckers...
or my fucking perversions...
I swear to god if I get slapped by these guys while I'm in my map form because I'm always opening the map and trying to figure out where the fuck I am.
It doesn't pause it?
Okay.
It does not?
Alright.
This is great to know.
Okay, let's...
Oh.
Can I just?
Oh, I can.
I have to combine it in my inventory.
Whoops.
Alright.
Combine.
Here we go.
I fixed it.
With glue.
Let's go.
It's crazy that people found out already that this does not pause the game.
Alright.
I have...
What?
I don't...
Where's the money?
Where was it?
Where the fuck was the money?
I didn't know there was money I need to find?
Oh my god.
Where the fu...
I have to go find money?
Okay.
I'm gonna save and then...
Oh my god.
I can't believe I'm fucking broke.
I have nothing in my life.
Like, what else does it want to take from me?
Like...
The crawl space?
What?
You mean like the little area in the... back to the...
The fuck?
Put it in C minor?
What's C minor?
This?
Guys, it doesn't matter.
I'm fucking broke.
I can't put anything in there.
I can't even pay...
Oh, bro.
Wait.
I can't even play the fucking jukebox.
Because I'm broke.
Wait.
I'm so...
I'm so fucking...
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna fucking freak out right here.
Holy shit.
Okay.
We're gonna...
We're gonna figure out where the fuck the coin is.
Where in the fuck is the coin?
That's gonna...
Where the fuck is the coin?
Is it in the goddamn cafe?
I...
Oh!
Oh my god.
I have to go to the cafe to get the coin and then...
After I get the coin...
Okay.
All right.
I'm gonna save my game again.
Hey, guys.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, Blackfire.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You're so money.
Like, how did I even know that that's where the coin was?
I swear, if I can hit...
I swear to god if I can fucking hit, trying to figure out where the fuck this cafe is.
Oh, I'm gonna...
Oh, nothing's gonna stop this fucking beast.
Oh my god.
If I just hug this wall, it should be fine.
Okay.
Okay, please leave me alone.
Please leave me alone.
Okay, this is the cafe.
Alright, there's like people here.
I swear to god, I swear to fucking god, stop.
Like, literally, stop.
Oh my god, stop.
Actually, no way!
No way it does that, you fucking...
Oh, freak!
Oh my god, no fucking way.
He projectile vomit?
He just had to projectile vomit on his dying breath?
He just had to?
He literally...
Fuck you.
Are you fucking... oh my god!
I don't care.
I don't even care.
Like, I'm already just...
You opened the door.
Oh my god.
Please!
I don't have the lottery.
Okay.
Oh, just why?
Why?
Why are you like this?
Why can't you think of something nicer, James?
Stop being sad!
Alright.
Alright, back to the bar we go.
I fucking hate these guys so much.
I've never hated a creature.
Why are you the way you are?
Why?
I... oh my god.
I swear to please let me go.
You don't even give me loot.
This is bad.
I shouldn't have looked at the map.
I shouldn't have looked at the map while this was all going.
Oh my god.
They're fucking ankle biters too.
They're goddamn ankle biters.
I'm running as fast as I can.
James is a real person.
He doesn't have the stamina for this.
Okay.
Oh, this... all this for a goddamn quarter.
Okay, two and then...
Alright, here we go.
Is that it?
The fuck?
The fuck's my music?
Is that the music?
Oh my god, James.
I did all of that for this?
This track fucking sucks, James.
This is my jab.
He needs to move on.
This is really the reason he's in this mess because he couldn't move on.
Oh, I broke the...
Oh, I broke it again.
I just fixed this.
James, I fucking hate you so much.
I can't... no glue can fix this anymore.
No glue can fix that.
Alright.
As a fellow James, I learned that we love to vandalize all property, put hands in random holes, attend furry convention, is very aggressive, very broke, and very depressed.
Thank you for that.
Thank you for your very first super joke.
Thank you for your chest piece.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Now we're in Kingdom Hearts territory.
Guys, I don't think I'm gonna...
Guys, I think I'm gonna...
I'm gonna softlock this game with the amount of heals I've used in the beginning.
I'm so gonna softlock.
There's no way.
I feel like I'm at softlock territory with the...
I already used up all my heals fucking doing this.
I...
Oh my god.
Sounds like a you problem.
Alright, we're gonna...
We're gonna call it here, chat.
Like, I think two...
I know...
I'm sorry that I couldn't play longer, everybody.
But I am sick, so I'm gonna...
I'm gonna call it here, guys.
Um...
That was a fun two hours of Silent Hill 2 going in.
So we're gonna rest now and, like, focus on getting better.
So no stream tomorrow.
I don't know if I'll be streaming on Monday.
We'll see.
But I hope you guys enjoyed the sneak peek of the early access.
I mean, it's been fun so far.
I feel like the remix seems pretty fun, uh, so far.
Um...
And, uh...
And I've been having a good time.
Other than the fact that I fucking hate...
I hate those...
I hate those guys so much.
Oh my god.
They're, like, the easiest enemies in the game, too.
That's the worst part.
When they're the fucking easiest enemies in the game and I'm having my ass kicked in right now.
I...
I'm so...
I'm so fucked now.
I just hope I don't softlock later.
I really hope I don't get softlocked.
Anyway...
Um...
As always, everybody...
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna rest my voice.
Um...
As always, everybody...
Stay hydrated.
Posture checked in.
Move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Cause...
You deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.